hello today I'm gonna be showing you a
new addon for google cloud that will
allow you to seamlessly import update
manage and share data from Salesforce
using Google sheets
my name is Tulsi Fishbach I'm from the
global technology partnerships team and
we're gonna be talking about how you can
use this add-on to improve the
collaboration of your team and save time
every day with your salesforce workflows
let's dive in let's start by looking at
a lead report in salesforce you can see
here that it's broken but down by status
and by lead owner today we're gonna be
focusing on a use case where you're at
the end of a quarter and you're looking
to update your lead data to better
project your sales prints the following
quarter this is just an example though
and you can use any object that you have
configured in your Salesforce instance
let's go ahead and jump over to the
add-on to see what this data will look
like in Google sheets so you can see
here that we have a sheet already open
let's go ahead and open up the add-on if
you don't have the add-on already
installed you can get it from the get
add-ons menu so let's open up the add-on
here you can see all the options that
are available for you to take using the
add-on let's start by pulling in the
data from that report we are just
looking at from the reports option you
can choose a recently run report or
search any report that's in your
Salesforce instance let's go ahead and
pull up the leads report by status as we
were looking at in the previous view
we're gonna import this data to the
current sheet which will wipe out the
data that we have there if you want to
keep the data in your current sheet just
open up a new tab you can see here all
the data from that report loaded in the
sheet we can see the status the owner we
can also see a lot of demographic data
about the leave this data can be really
helpful when you're looking to share our
data with people who might not have
access to Salesforce or when you're
doing those gear end reports and you
want to use all the power of sheets to
build charts and to just make better
business decisions now let's look at
what we can do if we import a custom
query from the import option you can
choose any object that you have
- in your Salesforce database let's go
ahead and pull up the lead object that
we are looking at previously you can
also at this point load the last data
import settings to quick start the
process if you previously were running
imports using the add-on with the lead
object selected let's go ahead and look
at the fields that we can import from
the next step here you can choose from
the fields that are available for this
object today we're going to be importing
the state as well as the status and this
allows us to focus on the data set that
we're most interested in changing let's
also import the company name and the
lead ID the lead ID is very important
because it allows us to know what object
we want to update finally let's filter
the data that we're going to be updating
first we're going to choose the state
and we're gonna filter on California
because that's the territory that we
want to make changes to today we're also
going to choose the status and you can
see here that we load in the pick list
from Salesforce so we follow all of the
data formatting requirements that you
already have configured in Salesforce
let's look contacted to focus on leaves
that we've reached out to but haven't
gotten back to us one thing I do want to
point out is that we do have a so called
iturra vailable this will allow you to
customize the query further than is
available in our graphic interface now
that we've chosen the data that we want
to import let's go ahead and get the
data you can see here that we pulled in
the state the status the company and the
ID these are exactly the fields that we
asked for and so we're ready to start
making our updates let's go into status
and we're going to choose two
unqualified some of these leads so we
can edit this just like any other sheet
in our instance and we can use formulas
or functions whatever is needed to make
those updates you can see here that
we've updated several of them to
unqualified we're going to go into the
update flow to see how we can make the
change on the
salesforce side inside the updates flow
will see that the options that we have
selected are highlighted in yellow this
allows us to know which objects were
going to be updating when we make these
changes it's very easy to make changes
we just choose a new selection and hit
refresh the selected range you can see
here that the new options are
highlighted in yellow now
now that we have the correct selection
we can go ahead and confirm the data
that we want to update you'll see that
we make some smart decisions to try to
make it easy for you to make updates to
your data through this process if we
look up the lead object that we're
updating we'll see that it's already
selected which we can tell from the ID
number you can see that there are three
functions available for us to make
changes the first is insert which allows
you to insert a new record the second is
update which allows you to update
existing records and the third is insert
or update which will update a data point
if it already exists or insert a new one
let's go ahead and choose update because
that's what we want to be doing today
you can see here that we've already
identified the ID and column D and that
the result of our update will spit out
in column E and this is just the first
column with no data in it so if you want
to change it you can do that just make
sure that there's no data going to be
overwritten when you make that change
now we can complete the last step before
we make the change which is confirming
the data that we want to update today
we're gonna unselect the state and the
company data because we didn't make any
changes and it'll just make the import a
little faster because we do run
validation on every single object that
we update so let's go ahead and execute
and see what happens here you can see
that the data has been updated
successfully as indicated by the green
message in column E if there is an error
it will be marked in red and will show
you the error message that we get back
in from Salesforce which makes it very
easy for you to be able to troubleshoot
the data as you're making changes so
there you have it now you can see how
you can seamlessly import update manage
and share salesforce data using google
sheets if you want to check out this
add-on for your organization check out
the link below to
stall it from the G suite marketplace if
you liked this video please like and
subscribe to see more content like this
[Music]